Tựa tiện hạnh phúc, nâng người tự ki được đó nhận và thủ hiểu.
Một quan cà phê nhỏ trên phố mai an tấn,
hà nội mỗi người lại dụng rằng khi tiến bộ đam phang lên báo có khách đến,
đức, mười xin tuổi, nhánh trong phân cà chỉ trong chưa đầy một phút.
Tất cả những viên ở đây đều làm việc giết nhàng,
chương nghiệp và điều đặc biệt, tất cả điều làm việc tự ki.
Cựa tiện hạnh phúc là tiên mua hình kinh tế sò anh với nước trung sáng lập,
nâng người tự ki được công hiện là người lao động, có lương, có thường và được lắng này,
phát triển theo cách chiếm.
Anh chung chưa sẻ rằng anh không có người thân tự ki.
Một thứ bắt đầu tư một cú và trả bất ngờ từ 12 năm trước với một đuổi trẻ đặc biệt.
Cái đập đầu đau đuyện từ đuổi bé và lời xin lỗi,
trong nó bị tự ki từ người mẹ đặc hiến anh bắt đầu hành xin tìm nhiều và đồng hành cùng cộng đồng này.
Anh nhận ra tự ki không thể chứ, như nếu đặt đủ mua chường,
họ hoàn toàn có thể xống đất lập và công hiện.
Tự đó, anh sẽ dự mua hình tích hợp cà phê, tạp hóa, nhà xách, không tây,
nên người tự ki vừa học mê, vừa làm việc.
Bà đầu, có bạn mất hàng tháng để cầm được kê chồn.
Có bạn chỉ có thể tập chú khi đeo dây thút hoặc nghe nhạc của định.
Mỗi người là một an số, cả năng mưa,
giờ rất cũng anh vượn tối cảm xúc của họ.
Anh chung từng phải chả giá khi đánh ra sai dễ hạn chữ đường của vinh,
một bạn tự ki phá hồng với trước lép tốt,
chỉ vì có thể vinh đã mệt như không đủ khả năng nói ra rằng cần được nghĩ người.
Sau khu sức đó, anh học cách kiến vả trở nên tâm li hơn,
trong gì sớm, đối thoại nhẹ nhàng,
tôn trong sự khác biệt.
Thử ra chơi qua, giới mái nhà đặc biệt ấy,
tương mươi một đá thay đồ.
Quang Anh, một cậu trai tự trở bối,
đập phá và bị khủ hồng tinh thần,
giờ chở nên điểm đạm và thành MC giữ rất nhóm.
Đức, một cậu trai học IT năm của lôn nở đủ cười.
Hương, từ cậu bè uc ích dơ đã là bếch trường của tiện và con biết cả ngoại nướp.
Ở đây, lương không khao, có không đương chỉ hai mình như đồng một người,
nhưng ra chỉ lời nhất là sự viên nhận.
Họ không làm việc viên áng sất,
mà viên nghiêm vui và sự thần khiến Anh chung nói.
Sauvà, mười năm và hơn,
mình như lời khác,
kự tiện thành phúc vẫn nhỏ,
nhưng rất mơ thì lớn, Anh chung tiền,
nếu con chung thay,
chúng ta có thể tạo nên một đại lộ giống lớn trong người tự ki.